[Music]
wait to see how miss Marcal looks on her
big debut counting down the days i want
to see everything the accessories the
dress well we know that she is in good
hands with her hair and the reason why
tops tonight's royal report on her
wedding day Meghan's hairdo is expected
to be created by london-based stylist
Miguel Perez who is also Amal Clooney's
hairdresser Perez did amals hair for her
Vogue cover and demonstrates how he
spouts her look in this Glamour magazine
video press told a British newspaper
that Amal introduced him to Megan and
there's buzz that the Clooney's are
attending the wedding who else could be
on the guest list
Vanity Fair dug deep into Megan's circle
of friends she's been skyping with them
to stay in touch that circle includes
quite a few celebs names that we're all
pretty familiar with Serena Williams
Priyanka Chopra Victoria Beckham either
people that are going to be loyal
they're not going to talk to the press
about earth and here is Harry and
Megan's wedding singer Welsh soprano
Allen Manahan Thomas has been personally
chosen by the couple to perform during
their ceremony along with a london-based
gospel choir and a 19 year old cellist
but how about pop icons like Sir Elton
John Ed Sheeran and the Spice Girls no
announcements yet but there's always
hope they could serenade the newlyweds
at their evening reception at Frogmore
house which is expected to be more
intimate and less formal oh it's gonna
go down that's what party we all want to
go to and the Megan is expected to
change into a swanky little evening of
course she is right
[Music]